My name's Kate Raworth.
I'm a renegade economist,
because I am passionate
about rewriting economics
so that it's fit
for the 21st Century.
Here's the fascinating thing,
I think we're living through
a psychological drama,
in terms of what business
can be and do in the world.
The 20th Century was dominated
by one narrow business mindset
that asked one overriding question -
how much financial value
can we extract from this?
But 21st Century business leaders,
designers, city designers,
they're asking a completely
different question.
"How many benefits can we generate
in the way we design this?
What else can it do
for the community,
for culture, for the living world?
What else can it give back to
the systems of which we're are part?"
You see, 20th Century industry
was degenerative by design.
We would take Earth's materials,
make them into things we want,
use it for a while,
and throw it away.
This is a linear,
degenerative economy,
it cuts against the cycles
of the living world.
We need to bend that around so
that resources are never used up,
they're used again and again.
So that we create an economy
that runs on sunlight.
That waste from one process
is food for another.
We work with and within the cycles
of the living world.
The thing is, business alone
can't make this happen,
creating a circular,
regenerative economy.
Imagine if every company said,
"Send us that shirt on your back,
that smartphone, that plastic bottle.
Return it to us and we'll turn
it back into something new."
We'd have a loop here,
we'd have another loop over here.
We'd have a series
of segmented loops.
Nature would laugh at us.
Nature doesn't turn a peacock
back into a peacock,
and a daffodil back into a daffodil.
Nature creates an ecosystem
of resource use.
She turns things back into building
blocks of oxygen, nitrogen, hydrogen,
and builds them up again.
Regenerating life again and again,
from building blocks to an ecosystem.
No one company can create
an ecosystem.
We need cities and we need states.
We need the world to work together,
to create ecosystems of plastics
reuse, of textiles reuse,
of metals reuse.
So that we work with and within
the cycles of the living world,
we mimic nature, who's been thriving
for 3.8 billion years.
If we want to stick around,
we'd be wise to learn from her.
Well, I never travel without
a bit of hosepipe.
This came from my garden shed.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)